i've got a very important political  issue kim kardashian is making headlines  as she always does pop culture magazines  are alleging that kim kardashian is  bringing back the side part so not  partying here in the middle party and on  the side i would just like to say  because you know i hate to say i told  you so and i consider myself something  of a profit and predictor of these  things i have had a side part since i  was about three years old okay i have  had the side part much longer than kim  kardashian and so if the side part is  coming back i would like to think that  it is because i am the setter of fashion  and a fashion icon actually in this way  i think more influential than kim  kardashian you know she's had the center  part for a long time i had the side part  who's responsible for this trend coming  back